how do i start that process of getting
into late night writing
um first of all i think it's a you know
it's a daily thing right you find
you get on you look at your news app or
you get on get online
find your regular place you go for that
news source
and um you start to look at the
the headlines that kind of resonate with
you that that trigger and emotion
and eventually you'll be able to
identify some that you know will
trigger an emotion with your audience
like you know i mentioned like
if there's anything about tom brady um
people love him or hate him
and there's gonna be you know if there's
a story about tom brady people will pay
attention
and they'll now if you can then write a
joke about it it's gonna
they'll be more involved than if it's
just the general
you know idea now it's one thing to just
have
relatability or recognizable or
something that's familiar
it's another thing that have people that
are either that are fans because when
they're
fans that's a big that's a big emotion
which is why
trump is so often used in late night you
know
we write what's in the news and trump by
design
makes sure he's in the news every single
day so who do you think we're going to
be writing about
so when people get upset about you
disrespecting the president
really dude i was i was on staff at leno
when they were making fun of uh
bill clinton for like 12 years after
monica lewinsky
it happened and it was still going on so
and i wrote some of those jokes
so get over it you know but i think the
thing is like you got to start writing
the goal
most of these writers write 25 to 40
jokes a day
um so that you know what you're that
threshold that's expected of you
um then once you're once you're good at
it
there are ways to reach out that are
kind of
built around the system uh one of the
things i would suggest to people
is um do a youtube you know build up
your fans my friend charlie
my student charlie behrens he has the
manitowoc minute
and it's a niche character he's from
like this wisconsinite that don't you
know
and he's got the he wears like a camo
windbreaker and he's up
in a hat and he just does he does local
and national news
but only for about a minute and 35
seconds it's this little quick thing he
does some relatability to wisconsin some
local stuff
some national stuff quick jokes nothing
really too offensive
just you know always keeping his
eyebrows up and you know keeping it
absurd as opposed to negative instead of
going like this and getting
you know judging people's ideals so he
went from when i first found out he was
doing this
a it was last september october he had
77 000 subscribers at youtube and he was
selling out rooms
of fans during one night he sold out
flappers main room four o'clock in the
afternoon on a saturday
who sells out a comedy club four o'clock
in the afternoon on a saturday
right i was blown away i went to go see
it and then talk to him afterwards he
goes i'm just doing what you told me to
do
you told you when i asked in class how
do we break through this i said get a
niche character
you know develop a social media appeal
keep it short and tight
and then people will start to identify
with the character
and but he even man he's got them
reminiscing about where they used to
live
all that stuff they want to come back
now he's at i think 150
000 subscribers that's great on youtube
in less than a year
and um now he's you know he's doing some
other things he's selling product he's
selling merch
and people love this character and his
jokes aren't that great
but the character is great and so we
love the jokes through the character the
jokes themselves mechanically you go
but the character sells the jokes so
that's like a sitcom in a way i have a
feeling this guy is going to have
either a special or a sitcom in the next
two years
you know because that character's so
like likeable
um but if you're doing something you're
putting out really quality material
every chance you get two or three times
a week
eventually somebody's going to take
notice if your numbers start and you
stay consistent your numbers really
start to go up there
and you know if he hits half a million
if he it's a million
um he's going to get a deal right so
that's one way that's outside the system
the other way
is when you're getting good and you see
you're writing 20
to 40 jokes consistently usually 25 to
um and you're putting out good content
you're running by your friends your
friends are going
hey man that's some really good stuff i
would listen to you
but you got to make sure you're getting
good advice um
then one of the things to do is to
follow the credit crawl on what shows
you're targeting
and maybe think about targeting two or
three
and follow the credit call in the credit
card you're going to see
a title called supervising writer that
supervising writer is usually the head
writer
then you'll find that you you can look
at the bottom of the credit crawl and
say oh it's filmed over at cbs
or you know most of them are in new york
called the production office of that
show and even if you just call the main
lot
and you say um i'm looking for uh conan
i'm looking for kimmel
or i'm looking forward to both these are
in la um i'm looking for
stephen colbert's show um then they say
we'll put you right through or else and
you get this phone call production
then you just say the name of the person
who is
william dad free hey bill dad free
yes speaking hi jerry corley you've
never heard of me
but you know i'm uh a writer
and when i could you take a moment and
share with me what specifically you look
for in a submission package
and then they're like if i'm a writer
and somebody called me
i go dude's doing what he's supposed to
be doing that's cool
kudos to him and i would take a moment
but if i was in a super hurry i'd say
hey can we do this another time i'm
slammed
i and i'd call back 30 times until he
picked up the phone again
you know and but is it's polite
persistence polite persistence polite
persistence
never take no as a no never take a hang
up as anything but
hey we're busy um if you stay persistent
you will get better and you'll break
break down that door there were eight
people that
quit there were eight jobs that could
become available in late night tv
just this during this last six months
that's a huge number
people deciding you know what they're
they're now good time to retire or
retire early
or move on or do whatever whatever their
motivation
anytime something happens like that
that's opportunity right so
if you stay persistent and you keep
writing you keep running as if you have
a job
your job is to get the job your job is
to have us have material ready for the
pitch
that's not even happening right now but
it will it'll be that opportunity
where uh somebody says hey send me a
packet or i would just send in packets
randomly and find some creative way of
doing it
you know um so it takes no this case you
know like for example
if i was bugging the head writer and i
already got a packet written
all i have to do now is tweak it to what
specifics
they gave you they gave me and
and it's just a little tweak and they
say yeah well i look for this this this
and this and if it was in la
i would get on my word uh and tweak it
then print it out put it in an envelope
call a messenger have the messenger
deliver it right over to the production
office
that day like three hours later he gets
a packet from me he'll go holy who
is this dude
you know that's impressive so that's
another way now not everybody has that
opportunity
you can overnight it or something do
something different but you got to stay
consistent
that's um it's a challenging
level to be you're working with a lot of
guys who are good at this or a lot of
guys and gals who are good at this
but they're always looking for new
talent
if i'm a head writer my job is to make
sure my host has the best material make
sure i've got the staff with the
most creative writers uh that come up
with good content
if they're not producing i give them a
little kick in the butt if they don't
work
if they are still not producing like i
need them to produce then they're
probably going to be let go and then so
i'm always looking for somebody good if
you're consistently sending a material
this guy's got great shitty right so
yeah prolifically
and you've always got some stuff coming
in
that opportunity may arise and you also
find different ways to get their
attention
one of my students she went goes to the
seminars at the
television academy of arts and sciences
they have these seminars and often have
like conan will speak or colbert will
speak
and she'll go to them and she's in a
wheelchair she just rolls right up there
and says hi you know and introduces
herself gets a picture with them tries
to give him a tape
and talks to them about how you get on
the show as a comedian
she's breaking the rules man and meeting
people and handing him
packets so it's just a matter of find
out where they're making personal
appearances
you know i had my uh my my friend lou
mojellowitz
from vegas a comedian he um
was in one of my workshops he goes how
do i do that i go you got leno
shows right up here at the at caesars
every friday night
so why don't you go down there have a
packet ready with a bunch of monologue
jokes
and uh go to the state find out where
the stage stage door is
go to the stage manager and see if he
can deliver it to leno
and um waiting out in front of the stage
door was bobby slayton
he sees this packet this comedian
looking dude walking up with a pack he
goes
you got a packet of jokes for jay don't
you and he goes yeah he goes i'm on his
plane with him i'll go i'll hand him to
him personally
and he did and two months later lou gets
a call from leno
you know and then um uh he he said what
do you want do you want to be a comic do
you want to be a writer he goes
i want to be a comic well i can't use
you then i said dude what you
you want the job right you said i want
to be like you jay i want to do both
um you know and then you say to him i'm
not getting off the
if you're on the phone with the decision
maker you say you know my job right now
is not to get off this phone until i
have a job writing for you right
you know that's that's the purpose right
now and so they'll laugh at that because
nobody asks for the job
they expect somebody just hand it to
them